here with more on that is her Republican
opponent who's making great strides has
shown up with a slight lead in the polls
recently Adam laxalt is with us uh this
is a winnable race this would be a
pickup for Republicans uh you are now in
the lead but it's still very close uh
let's talk about first the borders which
uh Nevada has to deal with on a pretty
high level
yeah look uh my opponent has said that
this is misinformation and the border is
not open this is what we are dealing
with in these huge Senate races where
these Democrats have unlimited money and
they get to absolutely distort their
record to our voters and they just do it
non-stop if she would stand up to Joe
Biden then we could actually get a
secure border she has that much power in
this swing state but instead she Contin
continues to stand with him and to see
the left lose their mind over the
Martha's Vineyard Plains I went to the
border and the people are dying on the
border now that's the humanitarian
crisis of the trip and for them to act
like they're going to try to go after
human trafficking charges for governor
DeSantis when human trafficking by these
cartels is an all-time high people like
Catherine Cortez masto are not standing
up for women that are being human
traffic instead they're lying on
commercials Sean we certainly need help
in my race at adamlaxel.com I can tell
you that but we feel strongly about the
race that people are going to see
through these lies and they understand
that this race will decide who has
control over the Senate I think that's
you have a critical race and it's a
pickup as I said for Republicans let's
talk about Cortez masto and her support
for this FCC nominee who has shown
nothing but disdain and hostility
towards conservatives and their opinions
uh it may be even more importantly
somebody that's been very anti-police
radical in her opinions
and you will put out a statement that
she must oppose Biden's anti-police FCC
nominee have we gotten any response yet
well of course not and and the media
still hasn't answered the question but
here's the key she is hanging on by a
thread this nominee if Catherine Cortez
masto actually did what she claims the
voters and stood against her president
and said this nominee is too extreme for
this appointment she could actually get
this nominee knocked out the Fraternal
Order of Police have said this is the
most anti-police nominee in the Biden
era and masto pretends like she supports
cops of course the Fraternal Order
police are standing with me and law
enforcement might say because they know
I'll be with them when they actually
need them she'll be there in rhetoric
but it is important to point the in this
area with this nominee with the massive
inflation reduction act with our border
she is the deciding vote that could have
gone against Biden and actually started
saving our country
well we're going to follow your race
this would be a very important pickup
for the Republicans uh only 54 days Adam
laxal thank you for being with us we'll
follow the race closely hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else